this is tony wilson reading for reviewer
alessandro barbossa
as you're slinking around air ducts and
planning a surprise attack on a helpless
scientist
it's difficult not to feel empowered by
carrion's approach to horror
here you aren't the ones slowly peeking
around each corner to make sure you're
safe
you're the one doing the hunting leaving
a gory trail of devastation as you pick
apart an underground laboratory one
department at a time
when carrion gives you the tools to be
the best be tentacled killing machine
you can be
it's a satisfying monster simulator with
engaging puzzles and clever combat
carrion star is undoubtedly the gooey
red monster you play as
simply moving around is immensely
satisfying it feels as though you're
constantly floating
with extended appendages latching onto
surfaces around you to feed into the
illusion of chaotic but
calculated traversal by making movement
effortless
carrion lets you appreciate how good it
looks in motion
from squeezing your red mass into a
narrow air duct to transforming into a
school of parasitic worms to swim
through grates
there are a handful of instances where
your size makes orienting yourself
slightly challenging
but they're small teething issues as you
learn to navigate around
when you consume humans you gain life
and grow while the reverse happens when
you take damage
as you progress through each level you
unlock new abilities which are directly
tied to your current size
when you're at your largest you can
cause devastating damage by sending a
flurry of tentacles forward and
viciously pulling anything in their way
towards you
at a medium size you can encase yourself
in spikes and roll around a room dealing
damage in all directions while your
smallest size offers more utility style
abilities like stealth and a handy stun
attack tying abilities to your size
makes combat dynamic where you're
constantly watching the damage you take
and adjusting your strategy as you go
it takes a bit to get comfortable with
the sudden ability shifts in the heat of
the moment but getting access to move
sets that let you dominate or flee a
fight when you need them feels great
these skills aren't just integral to
combat but also to carrion's
puzzle-filled stages
they make full use of your abilities in
varied ways an otherwise lethal bomb can
be used to clear debris blocking a path
if you can withstand its blast for
example
these puzzles require specific abilities
to solve rather than quick reflexes or
intricate movements
which means you'll sometimes be
backtracking through a level to find a
spot where you can deposit some of your
biomass and shrink accordingly to access
the abilities you require
the other side of the coin is more
punishing and i was forced to exit a
level entirely on a few occasions to
hunt down humans so that i could grow to
the size a puzzle required
while levels are filled with hapless
humans to feast on carrion features a
varied roster of enemies that provide an
ample threat to your progress
as powerful as you are enemies can
quickly tear you to shreds with handguns
flamethrowers and massive mechs with
gatling guns
it's difficult to use your size to
simply overwhelm a room full of armed
soldiers
encouraging you to tackle each one with
a formulated strategy
most combat encounters force you to
think carefully about picking off
enemies individually
using parts of the level that let you
flank them from all directions
levels give you the freedom to choose
multiple ways to achieve this
pipe systems let you quickly move from
beneath enemies to directly above them
for example
letting you break through glass
skylights and yank them inside the vents
you're hiding in
if you get exposed in the open you also
have numerous ways to flee
like by forcibly squeezing yourself into
small gaps on the walls or
breaking open grates on the floor to
make a hurried getaway
it feels empowering to scurry around the
edges of a room and pick apart a platoon
of soldiers with calculated efficiency
but also comforting to know that when
you over commit you have options to
correct your misjudgment
finding creative solutions isn't only
encouraged but it works well towards the
horror fantasy carrion strives for
executing your coldly calculated plans
sometimes requires an exactness that is
frustratingly not afforded by carrion's
control scheme however
moving a single tentacle using a thumb
stick is simple enough
as is pressing the trigger to grab and
let go of switches doors and enemies
but when combined with movement it's
difficult to parse which of your
tentacles are part of your body and
which single one
is under your control for actions this
isn't an issue when you're given the
time to solve puzzles or dispatch
enemies one at a time
but in the many instances where you're
thrust into bursting combat arenas with
danger coming from all angles
it's often easier to flail around while
grabbing things indiscriminately rather
than trying to direct
attacks accurately wiping out a room
isn't as satisfying when you don't feel
wholly responsible for its execution
some infrequent flashback sequences
where you play as a human scientist
instead of the far more interesting
monster also hamper some of carrion's
pacing
while not adding much to its sparse
story in the moment
these sections don't feature interesting
puzzles and sports slower and slightly
unresponsive platforming
and odd issues with ladders resulting in
far less satisfying movement when
compared to that of the monster
the way these moments eventually tie
into the surprising ending that comes
full circle with the game's opening
almost makes them feel worth it
but it's only once the credits are
rolling that you'll likely find a reason
to forgive their inclusion at all
carrion is at its best when it's letting
you live out its proposed reverse horror
fantasy
it excels at making you feel empowered
as an evolving lab experiment gone wrong
giving you ample opportunities to flex
your death dealing tentacles and tear
enemies limb from limb
it gives you numerous tools to wreak
havoc and it also uses them in smart
ways to find a good balance between its
gory combat and problem
solving carrion falters when it requires
too much fine precision from you with a
control scheme that doesn't allow for it
and is at its lowest when you're not
playing as its headlining monster at all
these are disappointing distractions but
carrion's main event is still a bloody
great time
[Music]
uh